yeah one of the best parts too uh i
think with the tucker i mean with this
whole trucker protest is that it
actually exposes those who on the left
who say that they're supposed to be pro
worker you know remember let's not
forget the left and the progressive
movement they're supposed to be the side
on the worker the middle class and
actually i was i was telling some some
some people that hey when mean sonic
produces 0-0 documentary if you would
watch this in the early 2000s or the
early 90s you would have thought
liberals produced it right because we
were taking the side of the worker going
against big pharma going against big
corporations so what's happening with
the truckers and the optics of the
truckers it's also exposing those in the
left and the media who say that they are
pro-worker or they're on the side of the
little man well now the little man's
protesting and they're still being
demonized so i think that's actually
kind of the best things to look for and
also
we've never really seen the trucker
movement ever uh uprising like that
right so like the black lives matter
that's more young people you know maybe
these anti-vaccine mandate stuff earlier
where like hey these people are fringe
right but these truckers are just
regular folks i mean you know really you
know my dad's a trucker you know so it's
a guy that literally goes into his truck
works 16 hours a day doesn't see his
family for two to three months i mean
these people are the true working class
well so so let's talk about your uh your
documentary you've got uh like the
truckers you had these people who were
considered essential they were heroes it
was it was not just medical workers it
was truckers it was first responders it
was firemen but it was also people
working at retail stores correct then
these mandates come out they fire the
nurses they they mock the truckers and
like you guys covered they they fire the
first responders it's not just like the
firing of it it's more about the
dichotomy of like two years ago
you and i don't know maybe rightly so
you held up
the hey these are our heroes and also
which i would surprise you with while
talking to a bunch of the nurses they
were like
actually personally i never liked being
called hero
and stuff like that because like that
like that's what i do for a living like
the fact that they're acknowledging it
right now kind of makes me makes me
really suspicious that by labeling us
hero right now they already are starting
off with the political motive so that's
one thing which i noticed and the second
thing was like yeah that was like two
years ago and now the same people who
just said that hey it's my personal
choice i don't want to i don't want the
vaccine right now
they were really cut off point blank and
not only that there are like so many
real little minutiaes here and the
nurses they had to wear different badges
in their hospitals like a pink badge or
like a yellow badge to let people know
that hey i'm not vaccinated whoa which
kind of invokes uh it's it's super
subtle like if you think about it like
they're wearing a pink badge while
everyone else is wearing their gen like
the the default badge because like
someone might come up to you and ask you
hey why are you wearing a pink batch
then you
by nature of the conversation are kind
of forced to
let people know that i'm not vaccinated
which kind of like infringes on your
personal boundary so all there are so
many little things which no one talks
about but two years ago these are the
same people
firefighters and cops yeah and
the thing
was you know we were surprised we're
like hey where's these you know
progressive journalists they're supposed
to be doing this the daily caller isn't
supposed to be taking the pro worker
site technically it's supposed to be the
progressive movement and one of the
firefighters that that we interviewed
that stands out to me is josh sadly josh
sally is a firefighter for the beverly
hills fire department since october
first josh sally has been placed on
unpaid leave till today hasn't received
the ch a paycheck he has a family of
four we meet me and sonny gotta meet his
wife and kids and he hasn't uh received
a paycheck um the city has him in limbo
as of right now he's on pace to be the
first firefighter fired in southern
california for not taking the vaccine
and these are the stories that we wanted
to tell the american people say hey
these are real people you know i know
you guys watch the la times and things
like that and they've been demonized as
these q and honors or anti-factors these
are are you know real americans and at
the same time the l.a times was was
praising these same people just a year
or two years ago so we wanted to give
them a voice and it kind of ties down to
you know it ties to this trucker
movement where the regular uh you know
average or working-class citizen has
been demonized from the media i mean
since basically the beginning of the
pandemic obviously you guys know 2020
the greatest transfer of wealth the poor
we got poorer the richer got richer and
it just seems like the working class
doesn't have any voice and and really in
any any media space right now i mean you
turn on msnbc they were demonizing
cheering i mean for me i think the the
part that was most i guess shocking was
just seeing uh these progressives what
they call themselves or people on the
left cheering on the firing of workers i
mean they're the first of all if a
firefighter gets placed on unpaid leave
the progressive woman's supposed to be
the first ones to say hey wait a minute
why is this worker being placed on
unpaid leave with no type of you know
core or or date um so it's for me that's
been the most shocking part of how no
one wants to give first responders a
voice and i highly encourage anyone in
the audience please watch the
documentary it's called hero to zero we
have our own website for it so it's hero
to zero doc dot com like that we could
avoid any time of youtube center and
please share these stories because like
this we can at least combat uh that
mainstream narrative i was thinking
about how it's challenging for
blue-collar workers to have a voice it
seems like in society and it's almost
like it's built that way because if a
blue collar worker starts a youtube
channel and starts getting notoriety all
of a sudden they're white collar they're
now they're making money off their
youtube channel and they don't need to
do their other job anymore and so like
it seems like the nature of of giving a
voice to anyone makes them white collar
the thing is to it ian is 90 of the
media is owned by these six large
corporations so anytime you even want to
start to tell real stories about
americans i mean those you know those
journals get cut off really quick you
know they say hey wait a minute we don't
want you telling that story we want you
to fall right back in line and and do
this and the thing is the problem with
of media in dc and new york is these
folks are stuck in their own media
bubbles i mean a lot of the a lot of
these journalists and and that live in
washington dc they don't know anyone who
lost a business during the shutdowns
they don't know anyone's kids who fell
under the depression or suicidal
underscore shutdown so they can never
relate to an average american i think
that's been my biggest takeaway yeah i
can attest to that personally i live in
dc i'm in the quote-unquote journalism
bubble politics like i usually like hang
around in like the capitol hill area
downtown area but i live in dc
but if and only when i travel for work
or for documentary purposes and i go to
all these places where all these
working-class people live it's also like
so apparent to me that these people like
the
it's so bizarre to me it looks
completely different take a look at this
story from 2018.
it's from geekwire clash at amazon hq
construction workers shout down council
members over planned attacks big
business i love this because these
construction workers are the actual
working class correct they have their
laborers they do work they build they
maintain the infrastructure these are
the people who make the machine you know
run on time and the people protesting
amazon are
leftist bourgeois
intelligentsia acting like they're the
working class
and this is what i think you guys what
you're working on it really exposes this
this documentary when they when they
come out they say oh we support the
first responders it's just hunger games
it's hungry it's when it's when they
parade around the victors and act like
they care about these people they don't
and then finally when those people tell
them i don't want to do what you're
telling me all of a sudden it's war all
of a sudden you're the problem i love
this video construction workers and hard
hats started chanting down the leftist
college you know faux working class
people really exposed well one thing to
tim really quick is uh during 2020 one
thing that i try to speak out is in 2020
amazon i mean for for amazon this was
brilliant you know amazon all they have
to do in 2020 is just you know if you go
shop on amazon on their on their website
all they have to put is
oh black lives matter and all of a
sudden the progressive movement who's
supposed to be pro-worker are like wait
a minute amazons are on our side you
just you know they say black lives
matter yet their own black employees
can't even pay their their wage or their
bills you know they have to live in
their cars their own black employees
don't have any health care um so that's
one thing also these corporations have
figured out is hey as long as we play
this social justice message we no longer
have to attend to the to the pro-worker
policies that the left wants those are
called platitudes i believe
corporations offer platitudes i think
it's i think the activists left are
basically some of this uh
this country's elite they really are i
know there's a lot of college debt don't
get me wrong but a lot of these people
are uh the highest salary earners in the
country correct the college uh people
with college degrees have have on
average the highest salaries they're
just angry they're not billionaires but
i you know when i think about like
around here this organization obviously
what you do is the most important aspect
here but it's ben townsend the most blue
collar he's the guy that fixes machines
can can code your computer for you can
like fix your computer like that's elite
keeps things running yeah the people who
are working behind the scenes to make
sure the infrastructure is operational
those are the working class people not
the intel like if i were to come out and
be like i i think it's it's unfair what
these people are doing i should get more
the government should give me subsidies
and abolish my debt it'd be like what
that's ridiculous it's the thing which
like the country has moved in towards a
point where people who work in the
quote-unquote information economy only
they will be
catered to like if you work with your
hands and stuff like that you are not
part of the conversation like being like
the whole trucker protest will never be
as cool as black lives matter is like
people will not put black lives matter
people will not put sorry uh the trucker
symbol as their profile photos as they
put black lives matter there's not going
to be a freedom trucker plaza in dc
correct they're not going to spray
freedom convoy on the ground maybe in 80
years but could you imagine i just want
you to imagine something real quick i
want you to imagine being a buzzfeed
employee getting paid 50 or 60 000 a
year to write listicles and then go hmm
i'm oppressed huh yeah my it's unfair i
deserve more meanwhile i just you know
you know what's funny is because
for me you know where i grew up the way
i've lived my life the people i met
i was never surrounded by these ivory
tower elites of new york city and that's
the thing about journalists that these
these people tend to be especially in
new york
well off
from families who are moderately
well-off they get access to colleges
colleges they many of them have debt for
sure
but the reason so so here's what happens
with these with these uh media jobs in
order to get a job in new york working
in media because they pay so little to
start correct you need your parents for
the most part to subsidize you exactly
and so what happens is all of these news
organizations are basically trust fund
kids or something to that effect and
then they're sitting there look i i
gotta tell you man they're people who
work at buzzfeed who get paid 50 60
grand a year
50 imagine getting paid 30 to 40 dollars
an hour to write about
a list of 10 cats that have funny faces
and then to say i'm oppressed yo i got
some dirt that needs tilling so we can
eat food tomorrow why don't you come and
shovel it and learn what work is
now and then um if you remember last
year me and
you know all these other reporters that
were on the front we got attacked by the
intercept and the big the big my biggest
takeaway was like wait a minute so we're
getting attacked by a journalist who
just sits in his manhattan apartment
who's been given a job because his
parents were in ivy league to reporters
who are on the ground actually uh
talking about the destruction to
working-class communities i'm like i'm
like that's actually media right there
that's that you know it's just it's just
a great round of how it's these uh you
know elite journalists who've really
never had a work hard mom and dad knows
everyone in the in the industry and then
they get in and they make like you said
50 to 60k 70k just sitting in a
manhattan apartment and the thing is
they're not even on the ground reporting
they're just reporting from their laptop
that's why they love the lockdowns
because they can have wine wine wine
delivery you breeds and then i love it
when they're like help help i'm being
harassed on social media it's like oh
too bad
yeah man it's it's we we've got
it's it's crazy what the internet has
done and we didn't expect this but this
is one of the things it's done it's all
of these journalists create these online
groups and they all talk to each other
and they they're they're the epitome of
ego that's what it is they all think
they're the most important people in the
world it's their job to tell people what
to think and what to believe they think
they are the most important people in
the world and they look down on on the
trades they look down on working class
people they look down on the people who
actually do the jobs to make this
machine work they think it's them
like even if they like
like
i don't know like to play the devil's
advocate like i would think like they
would probably think differently if they
like you know traveled or like went
outside dc new york california and
actually met people they're probably
good people but they just haven't met
anyone else who doesn't
partake in the information economy the
creator economy i somewhat disagree i
mean i understand what you mean by their
good people i think they could be good
people yeah but i do want to
differentiate there are journalists real
ones who travel around go on the ground
interview people you know obviously we
have journalists at timcast.com they're
not this i mean a lot of them they're
you know we're living out in west
virginia so we understand what work
looks like and there's a lot of
journalists who actually go to these
foreign countries go to brazil go to
morocco or whatever talk to people and
see what the world is like and they get
it
but we have this issue now where the
money is to be made in
flashy clickbait listicles
and 10 reasons to hate donald trump and
why donald trump is a fascist and that's
the kind of media they produce so they
sit in new york like you guys mentioned
they're in their apartment they don't
even go to work half the time and they
just type away here's why i think
trump's stupid and they get paid to do
it they call themselves journalists when
half the time it's opinion yeah
ellen or roosevelt quote i think that
great minds talk about ideas mediocre
minds talk about things and weak minds
talk about people i find that i've kind
of
engraved that into my soul i get almost
guilty talking about people like what a
waste of time why are we wasting our
time with this low this low quality
conversation but i also i took it so
extreme that i stopped completely uh
talking about people and that's a
mistake because we need to gossip about
each other's egos if we're going to
manage society it's a bunch of egos
together keep each other in check but it
is not the focus and when i see cnn
making it the focus that's when i'm like
no no that's why i don't even watch it
and so and sometimes when i come off
ignorant on this show when we talk about
what they said i don't care what i mean
i i i want to unders i want to know what
they said but it is not it's it's really
dumb people talking about dumb stuff
i'll give you an example of what i
really don't like and it's just me
personally i don't you know if you like
it by all means you but you you look at
some of these youtube channels
a lot of progressives even some
conservative and it's like just ragging
on someone like people making videos
specifically about you know this one guy
i don't like in naming him
within reason it's fine if you're
talking about joe biden the president or
congress you're talking about our system
of governance and the individuals who
have that power that i understand but
when it's like gossip you know what i
mean like you're like you're talking
about i'm not a fan of that stuff and
i'll give you an example the other day
we're talking about you know texts i get
from congress i'm not going to say their
names it's not them i care about as a
person it's it's the it's the idea of
what they're doing it's the actions
they're taking that i have an issue with
because the way i see it is
with even with joe biden you take joe
biden out of the presidency any democrat
can replace him and do the exact same
thing and that's a bad thing so we we
said here if we if we put all our
attention on just joe biden why he's bad
and then we we you know he leaves and
then buddha judge gets in it'll be the
exact same thing
no i completely agree and then i mean
just talking about the uh
the kind of clickbaity stuff a lot of
the kind of left-wing channels really
focus on you know hassan and sam cedar
you go on the channel it's all about oh
tim paul this temple said that so one of
the few people on the left that actually
respect and i think that he's his what
he's doing has been crucial for the
kind of movement on waking up people is
actually jimmy dore i thought you know
i'm thinking jimmy dore's actually even
though he you know you know he calls
himself a you know democratic socialist
or socialist he's been on the right side
of the issues when it comes to free
speech when it comes to this actually
these anti-vaccine mandates stuff he's
he's telling his his viewers he said hey
guys if you're a true uh populist on the
left then you would never agree with any
of this stuff like it's supposed to be
pro-worker to not take this out of the
corporations so he's actually one of the
few on that side that's that's that's on
the right side of this um he's honest
yeah not just that these progressive
creators and realize the pattern right
so they know uh what kind of content if
when i if and when i make
gets incentivized by youtube or twitch
whatever platform they're working with
right so
they know for a fact that if they
quote-unquote punch up right you know
punch up at temple punch up at uh joe
rogan for example they know that there's
no way that youtube's like not not gonna
like push that content up right so
they're kind of that that whole system
kind of it's like a feedback loop keeps
feeding itself the names become part of
the algorithm correct oh yeah absolutely
there was a really fascinating thing i
was reading uh i don't know i don't know
who was saying it maybe it was you they
said that uh they're watching a video
where a kid said they were playing like
fortnight and the kid said whoa he
almost just unalived me
and the reason the kids had unalived on
oh alive
because if you say kill youtube down
ranks you and and hides your content oh
my gosh so kids are changing the way
they brainstorm humanity man that's just
yes it is teaching kids to be counter
dependent on ideas is so so bad you need
to focus on the idea and then focus on a
different idea that's better than that
old one not on hating the old one i
think actually this would be a really
good idea we should we should task
someone with writing shadow english
a way to speak on youtube that bypasses
the algorithm that's like the plot of
1984
part of it there's like a second
dictionary dictionary to get monetized
yeah right i can't say any any of the
dodgy words and all the words
yeah that's a good idea like that that
no none of the funny words exist on that
dictionary and then you are safe for
your whole life that your videos will
make money what if you're like this is
the new alphabet written by alphabet and
nobody brought to you by google a b and
c are no longer letters these are the
new letters
i've been seeing a lot of political
youtubers like let's say you know
they're talking about something
controversial they always have to say at
the end of their controversial take hey
guys just want to let you know the cdc
says this and you know we're going to go
buy this i mean they only have to say
that to not get banned but that's where
we are right now in society i mean
youtube has
editorial guidelines you have to follow
i don't see how they should be protected
under section 230 if they issue
editorial guidelines
they if you issue editorial guidelines
then you are certifying what is being
published i have a friend who runs a
bodybuilding channel and he was trying
to
talk about arnold and he said arnold
schwarzenbord
no for real
you can't say his name
keemstar
had this had this issue happened where
he said the word and i'm going to be
very careful how i say it
e
dash
girl
when you say that fast it sounds like
a type of n-word and he got demonetized
and he posts and he's like look at what
because the the youtube caption system
had him saying
a specific because this auto generates
captions yeah so you don't know what
because it's
i don't know he said
hold on she said she's
and
e
dash
girl now i get it and when you put that
all together very quickly
the youtube
you know captioning system thought that
was
a racial slur so the caption is that the
official transcript of what the ai is
getting
i i wouldn't i don't know if there's a
direct correlation between the ai that's
like i don't know if the ai that
captions the word is the same that flags
the slurs
what is it going on what camera on
richie mcguinness ladies and gentlemen
gesticulating wildly trying to be a good
caddy he's trying to be a good guy he's
a very good caddie getting a beer
if one recognizes the word the other
whether to say whether there's a
different or not that i would imagine it
would flag it to the other program if
there's if there is another program it
might be the same one yeah another big
thing too was um on january 6 you had
kind of some you know left-wing
media groups like status coup
where all they did was actually just
live stream what happened on j6 like
literally no commentary no opinion like
literally just video
and youtube would demonetize their
account but then status coupe would then
sell that same footage to like cnn and
msnbc fox news and then youtube will
prop up those accounts so that's that's
another thing too where it's like
they're also um aiming at independent
news channels whether you're left or
right they're coming after you and
that's that was like one thing that i i
was pretty shocked by were like status
quo the same footage that they're
getting you know banned and getting
strikes on youtube they sell it to cnn
and then youtube props up you know cnn's
channel yep the same content they
all they did was live stream i mean i'm
talking about no commentary no this and
that just straight video footage and you
know they obviously put it on youtube
because it's a moment in history and
then they sold it to abc news cnn msnbc
and they came and i said hey guys we're
getting banned and demonetized for the
same footage that we sold to the
mainstream guys but the mainstream guys
actually get propped up by youtube i'd
like to know in like a conversation with
youtube admins or google admins is it
that you believe cnn is is more valuable
and more legitimate or do you are you
just kind of like you know they're trash
anyway but you're just playing along
because that's where the money is ian
what was it you said yesterday that
everyone said you rolled a 20 on like
eight things the first one number you
said something about a liberal economic
order oh the liberal economic order it's
uh yeah and i looked into that a little
bit last night too well i don't i don't
want to go on a tangent i'm just saying
you know you're you're asking a question
about why cnn is being propped up oh
it's part of liberal liberal
international order the u.s rules-based
economy yeah could it be that there is a
cabal
that they created literally in 1946 that
eisenhower told us hey we created a
military-industrial complex fyi that's
why i love eisenhower because he like
just blatantly was honest about it
and almost like i'm so sorry yeah yeah
he was in order to prevent world war
three we're going to be the world police
now sorry hey look don't let it get out
of hand because it's about to imagine
where we would be without youtube and
facebook and twitter though to be honest
whether it was intentional or accidental
whatever happened
we using the internet got a lot of
voices were able to to come up speak up
gain access get the microphone they may
be freaking out about it now but the
cat's out of the bag and i don't think
they can they can restrain it anymore i
mean they're trying really hard with
censorship but look at rumble the
censorship is being broken and people
are finding a way through satellite
internet that's very promising we'll be
beaming video from mars to earth and
also where it's also an interesting time
in kind of journalism and news because
for the first time ever i think in our
history
the corporate press doesn't have total
control of the narrative and i thought
one of the biggest examples of that was
the kyle rittenhouse situation and you
know obviously i was getting you know
media requests with you know what fox
news and all these channels and anytime
i would go on i said obviously what's
going on with rent house is a big case
for self-defense we know that i'm not
trying to understand that but in my
opinion i thought it was a bigger case
for how important that independent
journalism is because you know if it
wasn't for all those guys on the ground
on on on you know the united kenosha
where it was hula rosa's or bg on the
scene or drew hernandez
we would be stuck with the corpora with
the corporate media narrative and i
think for me the biggest uh thing that i
was shocked by was the amount of people
even during the ringhouse trial that
were that were contacting me or messing
with me saying hurry i thought right now
has killed black people i just found out
that he didn't i'm like
that information's been up for a whole
year thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time